Et voilà, terminé !
Il est pas mal mon bateau !
Enfin, mon bateau, c'est celui de Samantha Davies
qui participe au Vendée Globe sous les couleurs
d'Initiatives Cœur.
Le Vendée Globe, une course mythique,
la plus prestigieuse des courses à la voile.
Les bateaux font le tour du monde.
Je vais vous montrer.
L'aventure commence aux Sables-d'Olonne,
en Vendée.
Le département où je suis né.
46 000 km, sans escale et en solitaire. Alors les bateaux ne
font pas le tour du monde au niveau de l'équateur...
De toute façon, il n'y a pas de passage.
D'abordils mettent le cap au sud pour aller
chercher les alizés,
des vents qui soufflent d'est en ouest
et qui tournent dans le sens des aiguillesd'une montre.
Ils vont leur permettre de franchir
l'Equateur avec à ce niveau une difficulté majeure :
le Pot au Noir, une zone où peuvent s'abattre
des orages extrêmement violents et des pluiesdiluviennes.
Pour la suite, on va jeter un oeil
sur une carte, ce sera plus pratique.
Le voilà, le fameux Pot au Noir. Une fois cet obstacle
franchi, les bateaux contournent l'anticyclonede Sainte-Hélène.
Cette fois, ils profitent de vents
qui tournent dans le sens inverse des aiguilles d'une montre
et qui les poussent vers l'OcéanIndien.
C'est là que l'on prend réellement
conscience de la taille de l'Antarctique et
que l'expression "tour du monde", prend toutson sens.
Les bateaux naviguent au niveau de ce
que l'on appelle les "Quarantièmes rugissants".
Quarantièmes parce qu'ils se trouvent au niveau du 40e
parallèle sud. Vous savez, ces lignes imaginaires
parallèles les unes aux autres et qui permettent
de déterminer la latitude d'un point à la surfacedu globe.
Les Sables-d'Olonne par exemple, d'où sont
partis les bateaux, se trouvent entre les 46e et 47e parallèles
au nord de l'Equateur.
"Rugissants" maintenant,ça c'est de l'autre côté.
La mer et les vents sont déchaînés.
Normal, ça se voit très bien surcette carte,
Il n'y a absolument rien pour les arrêter, aucune terre
Là, les navires franchissent des caps mythiques.
Le Cap de Bonne-Espérance, le Cap Leeuwin au sud de l'Australie et le Cap Horn à la pointe de l'Amérique du Sud.
Quand on vit dans l'hémisphère nord,
on a un peu de mal à s'imaginerla distance parcourue.
Voilà ce que donnerait un tel itinéraire
au niveau du 40e parallèle nord.
Ilpasse par : la Turquie,
l'Azerbaïdjan, le Turkménistan,
traverse toute la Chine, l'Océan Pacifique nord,
tous les Etats-Unis et l'Océan Atlantique nord.
Bon, revenons au Vendée Globe.
Puis les bateauxremontent l'Océan Atlantique,
franchissent le Pot au Noir avec les mêmes difficultésqu'à l'aller,
vont chercher les Alizés pour contourner l'Anticyclone
des Açores et il rentrentà la maison.
Rien de raconter l'itinéraire,
je suis complètement épuisé.
Bon, il était pas mal monbateau,
mais si on allait jeter un œil sur le vrai?
Le voilà, le bateau Initiatives Coeur, en grandeurnature.
18 mètres de long, 5 mètres 70 de large,
le mât fait lui aussi 18 mètres de hauteur.
La surfacede voile peut atteindre 600 m², un joli bébé.
- Il y a quelqu'un ?
- Salut Jamy !
- Bonjour Sam, on peutvisiter ?
- Bonjour, avec plaisir oui.
- Attention la tête... Alors on est où ici ?
- On est àl'intérieur du bateau Initiatives Coeur qui
est grand à l'extérieur mais l'espace où je vis est tout petit.
- Tu vis uniquement dans cet espace pendant toute la course ?
- Oui, oui, j'ai tout ce qu'il fautici.
Devant, j'ai la soute à voiles pour rangerles voiles.
Derrière, je stocke un petit peu la
nourriture mais en gros, c'est les espaces vides
avec des cloisons étanches pour la sécurité du
bateau et là j'ai tout ce qu'il faut ici.
- Ça, c'est le poste de navigation ?
- Exactement, la navigation,téléphone satellite, la table à cartes
où j'ai l'ordinateur pour la navigation, le GPS, la
stratégie, aussi la communication, e-mails...
J'envoie les vidéos depuis le téléphone satellite qui est
ici aussi. Je peux commander la télécommandede pilotage.
Je peux barrer le bateau depuis ici et
j'ai les infos sur la force du vent etc...
Et puis juste derrière, j'ai un petit lit. C'est une petite
couchette avec un matelas en biais parce que
le bateau bouge beaucoup, il faut que je sois
bien amortie et là, je peux vraiment ajuster
si ça s'agite, ça penche beaucoup, je ne tombe pas.
Et je peux voir la navigation,
les chiffres, la vitesse du bateau depuis mon lit.
- En étant bien calé. Alors dans un bateau,
il faut se nourrir aussi, Où se trouve la cuisine ?
- Oui on mange, il y a la cuisine. C'estun tout petit meuble.
- Là ici ?
- Avec juste ici un réchaud, une gazinière de camping
qui bouge aussiavec les mouvements du bateau.
- Et puis alors dernière question,
sur un bateau on fait satoilette aussi ?
- La salle de bain c'est ici.
- Ah c'est ça, la salle de bain ?
- En fait, j'en ai deux normalement.
Il y a une c'est des toilettes et l'autre c'est la douche.
- De la même couleur ?
- Même couleur mais je vais le noter dessus.
- Ah oui, il vaut mieux pas se tromper.
Bon, on est un peu à l'étroitici.
On retourne
faire un tour à l'extérieur ?
- Carrément, oui.
- Allez !
- Là, on est dans ton jardin ou sur ta terrasse
plutôt, ça manque un peu de verdure
mais il y a une très belle vue sur la mer.
Alors à quellevitesse il va ce bateau ?
- Il va jusqu'à 35 noeuds, c'est à peu près 50 km/h.
- Ça c'est énorme pour un bateau.
- Bah oui, c'est méga rapide.
- S'il peut atteindre une telle vitesse c'estgrâce
à sa surface de voile, à sa silhouette mais aussi
à ses appendices qui sortent de chaque côté
qui sont énormes et qu'on appelle des foils.
- Oui Jamy, ces foils sont capables deporter le poids du bateau.
- Alors ses foils sont capables de porter le poids du bateau.
Ne bougezpas, je vous explique. Samantha, tu m'attends ici,
je vais dans l'atelier
et je reviens tout de suite.
Parfois il ne suffit pas de regarder la réalité en face.
Il faut aussi l'observer de profil.
Vu sous cet angle, un foil ressemble à une aile d'avion, en coupe.
Grâce à ce profil, quand le bateauavance,
l'eau est déviée vers le bas
comme le fait l'aile d'un avion avec l'air.
Ensuite,
c'est le principed'action réaction.
Quand un corps exerce une force
sur un autre corps, il subit en réaction
une forced'intensité égale
dirigée dans le sens opposé.
Très concrètement, le foil dévie l'eau vers le
bas et par réaction, une force d'intensité égale
s'exerce vers le haut.
C'est ce qu'on appellela portance.
Le bateau est moins immergé,
il y a moins de résistance,
moins de traînée,
il vadonc plus vite.
On essaye ?
Allez, c'est parti !
Bon Samantha, on va peut-être faire demi-tour
parce que j'ai des choses à faire
pendant les deux mois qui viennent.
Allez, à très bientôt...si je rentre.
J'avais oublié de vous dire, si je suis monté sur
le bateau de Samantha Davies c'est non seulement
parce que c'est une excellente navigatrice
mais aussi parce que je suis ambassadeur de
l'opération Initiatives cœur.
L'objectif consisteà réunir des fonds pour sauver des enfants qui
sont atteints de graves maladies cardiaques et
qui nécessitent une intervention chirurgicale qui
ne peut pas avoir lieu dans leur pays.
Pourles soutenir, il vous suffit pendant toute la
durée de la course d'aller sur la page Facebook
d'Initiatives Cœur ou sur le compte Instagram
- les liens apparaissant en description -
de vous abonner, àchaque abonnement
les sponsors versent un euro
à l'association Mécénat Chirurgie Cardiaque qui
se charge d'accueillir les enfants en France
et de financer l'intervention chirurgicale.
Cesenfants ont besoin d'un nouveau souffle pouravancer
comme le bateau de Samantha
a besoinde vent. À très bientôt.
Je t'en refais une entière, tu vas voir pourquoi.
Des orages extrêmement"violentes"
et des pluies délu, dilu... Oh mince...
Oh... Hop ! Reste ici toi !
De déterminer la lattitude
d'un point à la surface du...
Très concrètement...